[Music]
hey party people welcome to
mulan 2020 honest trailer commentaries
where i'm gonna make a man out of you
two chuckleheads joestar
lon harris thanks for joining me let's
get down to business
if this is uh your first time watching
this show uh weird but we
talked about the honest trailer in our
uh in more depth we we play some deleted
scenes
didn't make the cut we respond to viewer
questions and comments from people just
like you
and then we tease you what with what
next week's honest trailer is going to
be
um and more importantly or as
importantly uh we have something that we
want you to do this friday
uh coming up which is to enter into our
fandom five trivia show
uh where we will be asking disney trivia
questions and you will be winning
real us american currency which i think
is still worth something but you can win
up to uh
650 bucks by answering questions about
zazu so
uh that's that's easy money right um
yeah come on link click that link in the
description sign up for that also
we have as always our link for uh direct
relief which is now supporting hurricane
relief for the gulf coast
if you got any cash to spare from all
those disney trivia questions that you
got right
um but enough about that on to mulan um
don't tell them all the questions are
about zazu
that's all zazu-based it's just a
hundred zazu questions
and mr bean you know
um let's see so mulan 2020 this is
another disney live-action remake
it carries on the long grand tradition
of being a movie
yeah yeah do their credit like i've been
long saying that i prefer when these
remakes like kind of do their own thing
and don't feel
so tied to the original and this maybe
more than any of the others we've seen
really does try to take the story and
make something new out of it rather than
just
recreating the experience we already had
i think it i think it did i think the
issue with it though was that they never
decided what new thing they wanted to
create
yes and so it the whole time
yeah it was just like what do you want
this what do you want the story to be
about
uh so for new people who maybe aren't
familiar with the legend they're getting
a very unsatisfying mulan movie and for
people who love the animated one
they're not even getting pandered too
well you know like they didn't even like
they were like oh we're going to
incorporate the songs and the music but
like they weren't even the real part of
the score
so yeah they managed to um rise of
skywalker it where they've managed to
please nobody
um seemingly although look that said uh
it's getting good reviews um and isn't
it
it's like 75 80 or something um
and uh wow there's there's definitely
fans coming out
in support of it and i think that all
things being said
uh this is a beautiful movie um i think
nikki carroll did a great job
framing it and and staging it and just
making everything pop
but there's a story to be told and it's
just
the tepid it's a tepid boilerplate thing
that also manages to try to be
two things at once it's they didn't
solve
the big narrative issue i have with the
original mulan so now both movies have
the same problem which is
we don't we don't know enough about what
mulan
really wants and who she really is we
only know her in terms of what she
doesn't want like she doesn't want to
just be a wife and to do the traditional
routine to get
married she wants to have her own
identity which is a great
starting point but we never know like
what are her actual aspirations and
hopes and dreams aside from like save
family have honor and like i i just i
wanted them to
this was seemed like an opportunity to
really deepen that character and
complexify and like
enhance our understanding of who she
really was aside from this situation
that she's in
and they sort of don't she just once
again becomes an avatar for like
young chinese girlhood and toughness and
all of these sort of themes but we still
don't get to know her as a character
well yeah i mean i have a slight
slight difference of opinion for milan
in that i think that this time
they tried to uh give her more of a
uh more of an inherent character trait
which
i think kind of undermines what she does
in at least the first act of the film
where she clearly wants to be a warrior
she wants to fight she's a martial
artist scenes where she's training but
even that's not really like we never get
a scene where she actually talks about
her like desire to be a warrior or
anything
well she's like chasing the chicken with
a stick and she's doing
she's doing martial arts demonstrations
and basically she's
they they frame it they seem to frame it
and maybe this is a problem with the
movies
it's muddled and we took different
things away from it they seem to frame
it as if
uh she is this she's a martial artist
she wants to fight
but society is telling her she can which
to me undermines the decision to go
uh in her father's place because it's
like she's not doing it to save her
family so much she's doing it because
she wants to fight
yeah i mean that's there but it's not
it's like just
barely there and it's like i feel like
even that like you're right that it kind
of muddles the sacrifice angle but i
would still be okay with it if we felt
like that was a strong through line like
she always felt like she would be great
as like a warrior or a
like a the emperor's guard or whatever
and and but
but we never it's really more of a
rejection of her traditional role as
like a wife and a woman in this society
than it is an embracing of
war and fighting and soldiering and any
of that it just
i i think muddled is the is the right
word like
that among above everything else should
be the clear
direction it's like here's who moulin is
and here's what her dreams are about and
here's how she's gonna go about making
them a reality yeah
i the impact of her having
chi which we can probably talk about
later um would have been
which i don't believe is how it's
thought of in china is like something
either got it or you don't it's the it
factor baby
i'm pretty sure that's not what it is
but i think it would have been more
uh more clear if she lived in a world
where men were able to use their chi and
express their chi freely but
she had to keep it uh hidden and tamped
down
whereas like she seems to be the only
she just seems to be like a wizard
that lives in like this and i think you
guys are both right and that that's
where the
the muddling is the thing and that's
where the this movie didn't
make a decision about what its movie was
going to be because
it did seem from the beginning to me we
see her training
i have zero problem with her being a
kung fu badass
like that and people who
freaked out about that confused me
because it's like how do you watch
kids compete in the olympics and go like
wait a minute
how is she an expert gymnast like
because she trained like we saw the kid
training
but then they didn't change the story
to fit that arc this this overqualified
woman who's being held down by her
culture like they didn't change the
movie
uh because the movie still has to be a
tepid cliff notes
of their animated story that they stuck
with and so yeah like
i mean it's too many masters and so it
serves no masters
the the gong li witch story line has the
same
kind of issue which is that she comes in
first she's just a villain
and then she makes this sort of very
valid case for what she's doing that
she's opposing this oppressive society
and she wants to bring in this new
regime that will
be more favorable to her and then it
just immediately jumps to like and then
she sacrifices herself and like it's or
that that plot line is over and
it just goes unresolved it's just a lot
of interesting ideas that kind of get
raised
but then we never like capped them and
the happy ending ends up being mulan
and we make this point in the trailer
sort of like reinforcing this oppressive
system that the witch was opposing
and so it's like does the witch get
anything that she wanted by the end it
just sort of seems like it becomes
a journey that's on behalf of all women
and then it just becomes like well
things work out for mulan so good enough
right yeah it seemed like the the the
tension between the two was like
uh there they were clearly making a a
comparison between
the roles that mulan and this witch have
had to play but the movie comes down on
the side of mulan which is like
i'm gonna work within the rules and not
really
it ends on a sort of beat of like well
if only every woman could just
literally save china then things might
really start to change you guys like get
on it get on it ladies
yeah anyways uh we'll we'll talk more as
we watch the honest trailer of
mulan 2020 roll it based on the chinese
legend that already inspired a beloved
animated feature
comes disney's all-new reimagining of
premium vod pricing strategies to
service an evolving consumer dynamic
[Music]
uh that's taken almost verbatim from uh
a disney q2
earnings call you guys all talk about
how much you love these characters and
love these things that's how the people
make the decisions talk about
them nothing captures walt's magic quite
like uh
consumer dynamics pvod baby
um i i still don't know i don't think we
have final confirmation on
how uh how this experiment worked or not
but ryan was bringing up earlier it's
it's not a good sign when they're
rolling out the excuses of like yeah the
con there's a lot of controversy around
it
and uh you know they seem to be kind of
hedging hedging their bets and
expectations
we were sort of saying before we started
streaming uh like the the
coming out with it and then immediately
announcing that it's gonna be free on
disney plus in december
like wow you are really you're going for
a niche audience of people who just like
have to see this
right now yeah and like if it was if it
was super kid-friendly and there were
like a lot of screaming toddlers around
the country like demanding mulan
immediately
i could almost see that maybe working
because parents would just be like it's
quarantined i give up just was about
goodbye but this is not a toddler movie
this is this movie right yeah you want a
trolls world tour
you want uh an add uh uh sour straw uh
shoved into uh yeah like you don't like
like
this is very serious and dour uh yeah
it's like you want his first braveheart
like
yeah you want the mulan one and a half
of this where the phoenix gets into
wacky scrapes like that
yes this movie doesn't have a cronk who
can get into his own
that's too bad that's where he should
have had a chrome movie really needs a
cronk who could just get into
a different groove yeah i'm sorry it's
just brought
reminded me to my uh that i played
through the um
boss baby choose your own adventure
netflix series yes
yes which is truly dystopian and
something that we should probably
revisit in an honest trailer or a choose
your own adventure story
yeah it's like you have to pick your job
at baby corp yes you do
i thought it was just a show i didn't
know it was a choose your own adventure
oh no you become the baby wow
i'm in well we'll do a live play through
that later uh let's get back to mulan
sorry i got distracted
link consumer dynamic
[Music]
remember mulan the girl who used her
wits and determination to grow
strong and save an empire forget her and
meet this natural-born killer
what a cat who's just waiting for an
excuse to kick something sharp through
your chest
what's that move oh and while we're at
it you may as well forget all those
songs you loved
and your first animated crush and the
funniest disney sidekick since the genie
oh man no mushu if any film needed some
eddie murphy to lighten the mood it's
this one
okay let's get this show on the road see
prepared
um i look the the songs in mulan are
really good
um i i was castigated when i said some
of them were
uh so-so in the in the animated honest
trailer i
will uh the will of the crowd has broken
me to the point where i will say
they're very good songs to the point
where i was missing them
in this movie because they would just
give you a little taste of it they just
give you a little
little bit of i'll make a man out of you
or like they drop a lyric into a line of
dialogue but then
that's that's almost worse than not
doing it at all well it makes like
your tease yeah if you if this is your
first time seeing mulan
then instead of getting like um i'll
make a man out of you incorporated into
the score
like as an ongoing motif in the movie
you just get confused because you're
like hey what was that weird moment
where before they started training the
music just once in the whole movies very
specifically went
and like everyone looked at the camera
what what they did work some things into
the score though right like there were
there were
moments of um but it was always weird
always in that way
it's never just like integrated it's
always like you go into the scene
and then they would put like
[Music]
on to the next thing and it's just like
yeah it is it's it's
it's it's just a self-aware shout out to
the fans
it's not at all like baked into the
movie like you'd sort of expect
like i think joe's right that it doesn't
ever seem like organic it always seems
like ah
remember i mean that's the issue of of
every disney remake is like
yeah it feels like the characters in the
movie have all seen
the movie that we grew up with and are
like kind of yeah
acting their way through it instead of
right actually being in that situation i
don't know if that makes sense
yeah no i mean the lion king i think is
the most explicitly
like that where the whole movie is
almost like it would rather just be
split screen
like with the old and new so you could
be like oh look it's exactly the same
uh so i mean this one's not that bad but
yeah those musical moments definitely
feel like i mean you either make it feel
like originally part of this movie
or just don't bother like i don't get
why like splitting the difference would
be a thing
yeah all right let's keep going
c prepare for an absolute feast for the
senses
full of vibrant colors and sumptuous
landscapes
that will be totally wasted on your
crappy tv as you soak in locations from
the beautiful forests of new zealand
to some of the most stunning regions of
china ignore that
in this gorgeously rendered cinematic
experience that continues the
live-action disney tradition
of being a cliff notes version of a
story you already know
oh so pretty wake me up for the big
fireworks finale
oh they cut that too that's a shame
that finale was pretty dumb the biggest
issue i had
was is this how they built buildings
back
like why would there be a crane dangling
a single wooden plank
over the center of this structure
they're building like
it looks like it's casino royale but
that's set
in contemporary times it does seem very
uh
uh i think that that is how they build
stuff but it does seem very like ready
for an action sequence
like right i mean that's how they build
stuff like the the you know like the
bamboo
around but i just mean like this crane
wooden crane thing dangling a single
plank from a real
yeah yeah two guys with like yellow hard
hat should be eating a sandwich on
either side of it it just looks like so
out of place to me like obviously there
so two people can stand up
yeah the wayne drilled two guys are just
like oh well my job is to walk this
plate glass back and forth every second
right yes yes yeah their main export at
the time if my history is correct is
dramatic locations for
uh
there was nothing wrong with the i
thought the the animated sequence when
they
uh it added a nice note of levity to one
of mulan's many kills which was that she
kills uh
that guy with uh fireworks it was
awesome
yeah it was fun yeah it um
kick an arrow through his chest it's not
super fun to get into
a story structure essay in the middle of
an honest trailer but like
uh you know for this lame finale i mean
we might as well
you know she they do the the landslide
which is supposed to be the reveal where
everyone's like oh man she's a lady and
look at all the cool stuff she did but
none of them
see it right and then donnie yen's just
like
you're in charge now i yeah it's
it's how about the emperor uh uh just
soloing
uh the the
backing up if you kill the emperor does
the empire of china
just go away or does his presumed air
take over
because i think you get put in charge i
think that's the rule i think yeah
mom gets put in charge you get his hat
it's so weird on a few levels i mean i
think and this is an issue with the
original story as well like i believe
the animated story is the same like
the fact that the main villain uh bori
khan
jason scott lee doesn't even know it's
not even that he hasn't
met mulan he doesn't even know who she
is like she's totally
incidental until that very last scene
where someone goes oh and by the way
there's a lady and she's very strong and
she's leaving the army and she said it's
your way
yeah you really need to to lock that
down either either make the witch the
primary villain so you have that
that back and forth and it's a real like
antagonist situation
or they've got to learn about her
earlier it just like
dramatically is so unsatisfying that
he's killed by this person he didn't
even know about
a few minutes ago like obviously i'm
just surprised that the emperor was able
to just
sneak away with no guards or be left
completely unguarded and then slip away
by himself to be like i'm gonna fight
you i will fight i mean if you're
if your emperor is also jet li like
that's right
normally i would agree with you but
we're talking about the one
but that's another obnoxious i know
you're making a joke but i honestly
think that with their winky cliff note
meta stuff like i honestly think
that in the script they were like it's
jet li they'll get it
like i think they're just like people
know these actors
it's it's fine yeah all right
uh let's keep watching what else we got
oh they cut that too that's a shame
follow me as she goes undercover in the
world of men
you're a good man which as all men know
is a world of grab ass cuddling and
sniffing each other's necks
what you guys don't sniff your bros too
okay fine more next for me
oh john has a lot of fun out of his time
is refreshingly asian
including the exact opposite of harvey
fierstein i like my women
[Music]
as we watch move on struggle against the
constraints of a sexist
empire until she lives her truth
rises like a phoenix and fights to
preserve the same empire that oppressed
her
consorting with women in any way penalty
death then becomes an official tool of
that oppression
join our greatest decorated warriors and
the emperor's gone
hashtag girl boss prepare for two hours
i feel like we've kind of covered this
already in the intro um
but yeah uh uh is it muddled or is this
uh what's was this intentional are they
just trying to please everybody
yeah i think it's more like how what's
the lightest sprinkling of
girl power we can put on this without
offending anybody but with making it
clear like that's what it's about
well there's also no way like when
you're literally making a movie
that's just designed to make a bunch of
disney bucks in china there's no way
you're going to make a movie
that's like hey maybe there are some
things about this culture that are
incorrect and maybe this government's
doing some bad things you know they're
they're not they're never gonna do the
scene where
khan is like oh actually i'm starting
this rebellion because there are some
uh changes i'd like to see made in the
uh regime no he's just a a crazy
uh just personal revenge personal
revenge
and yeah yeah i just don't see what the
next necessity was
of that final final beat of putting her
in the emperor's
guard i thought it was like it was nice
or i think it would have been more
cohesive if she just was like i'm
turning it down i'm just gonna go
with my family which is both the
original
like folk tale or the poem that it's
based on
and the animated movie that's what
happens in both of them she's like i
don't want to be a professional soldier
this is for my family i'm going back to
my family
and like but now in a more empowered
like they recognize her ability and
she's no longer going to just have to be
somebody's
wife like i don't get why you wouldn't
end it that way either her like
officially
becoming like a like a cop for the
emperor is it
a weird way it was a weird choice and
even even there the way they wrote their
movie
the one thing she's accomplished
that anyone except just like jet li saw
her fight
what's his face but
um but the one thing she's accomplished
was correctly telling donnie yen
that boycott was on his way to the
palace that's the one thing she did and
then donnie yen's like you're great
you're you're in the club like they
don't they
no one really sees her do any of them
well they had the i am spartacus
moment with you know i i believe mulan i
believe mulan
um so her her squad mates yeah i'm sure
they don't give a very good reason to
believe her
in that moment like it almost seems like
the sort of thing like she'd give them
the information and then they'd go
confirm it and then you'd have that beat
of like you were right all along but it
really
bothers me it took one shot of
everyone in that defensive formation to
be just poking their face
like poking between the shields to watch
her run up that mountain and someone
being like no don't do it
and then like it just took one moment of
that
for any of that to track and that it was
that was a weird
yeah but i mean all you have to do is
save the emperor's life to win some
serious
that's a brownie points um yeah
all right you give you the hat you now
you wear the hat let's keep going
prepare for two hours of people talking
about their chi
the cheaper base the universe and all
living things which is powerful foreign
it's over 9000. well mulan crosses
swords with this inequality just get
demonetized
[Music]
was there a disney executive that was
like hey guys
i'm reading the script i don't know if
an american audience has ever seen one
of these kung fu films
or can we come up with the reason to
explain why people do
kung fu like i didn't watch crouching
tiger hidden dragon
and be like i need um a weird power
explanation as to why they fly on trees
like i they just did i do i mean
i think it's just it was maybe maybe the
script started as a
as a star wars thing maybe this is benny
often twice a star wars thing and they
just
replaced force with chi because chi as i
understand it
is like is everything in in
you know a traditional chinese culture
it's like just it just means like life
like life force
it's it's energy and i believe like the
idea is
i mean like but it's weird to say like
you you have chi you don't have cheese
you don't have cheese in a lot of
martial arts movies and also avatar the
animated series uses it in this way it's
like
you unblock your chi within to like
unleash your
own ability and clarity and power
but it's not like you have like a chi
level
and you have a chi level and like we can
compare our
qi level and like whoever's got more chi
is more powerful like it's not a
it's not that kind of power level thing
i get it
i just don't think it was necessary at
all
where people can do this yeah yeah i
didn't watch kill bill and go
wait a minute how did he just flip onto
her sword like he just does and it's me
i guess they felt like because it's
presenting itself as sort of historical
but also has these
magical realistic magical elements like
they wanted to kind of explain that
disparity whereas for a chinese audience
like
they're used to seeing sort of
mythological
stuff mixed up with the historical but i
don't know i agree that you probably
didn't need to and you could just have
like
there's a bird witch in this world why
not with it
yeah maybe she's born with it maybe it's
mulan's chi alright
let's keep going wow a mulan crosses
swords with this indigo montoya wannabe
in honor of my father this
is where you and this awesome bird lady
whose unique perspective on the nexus of
power and womanhood
is way too nuanced to survive the movie
but hey
this is a war film at its heart people
are gonna die and most of them thanks to
[Music]
mulan
easily outpacing elsa or any of the
other disney princesses
yeah there's also one sequence of this
where they pass by like a battlefield
and like they're using like stacks of
armor to kind of stand in but it's also
gotta be the killings
with disney's latest live action remake
that tries to be a fantasy kung fu movie
a war epic a fun kid's quick and an o to
female empowerment
yet doesn't explore any one of those
lanes deeply enough to be satisfying
but hey at least it went over well in
china right wasn't that the point
oh come on disney how do you get out
pandered by michael bay
now this is a master at work we gotta
call the central government for help
[Music]
sword art offline chai curious
nick schmidt and winston falcon punch
you either die a hero or you live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain
two lawns hmm yes a tiny net is a
desonance
and a gender reveal party very topical
right now
[Music]
that's how we're all gonna die
it's a girl hey the emperor's new dude
only one of the four riders in this was
a man and i'll bet it was his idea for
mulan to let her hair down before a
fight
the buns are strategic dude
yeah i kept expecting her flipping
around a bit
hair out of her face um also uh
none of the writers chinese i believe no
no
a lot a lot of white folks behind the
camera on this one what i helped to
maybe uh
take a pass from somebody who grew up in
china
yeah i feel like you say would do if
disney wanted to do their first epic
wushu movie
maybe hire a director that does them i
don't know
it's weird because like yeah i mean the
first mulan movie
did the same thing and it wasn't popular
in china so you'd think that they
wouldn't
make that mistake again it's also just
so many filmmakers
are so intimately familiar with the
genre they were trying to do and you
would think that would be like a selling
point would be to get somebody who's
made
these kinds of martial arts epics or
chinese historical epics like
what's troy hark doing right now like
get get him on the horn you know like i
just it just seems weird
to go with you know like then not that
nikki cairo's a bad
filmmaker like you know i get it and
like that that's cool like
it is i agree with joe it's like a great
looking movie but it is a strange
decision to not bring in
anybody with more experience in this
particular genre behind the camp
at least in the story department i know
they had lots of help from the chinese
government in lots of other ways
sure yes just not in like actually
telling the story of mulan
yeah oh there you have it um i don't
know if they're quite ready yet but
let's queue up some of those
uh outtakes but not before i tell you
once again to sign up for the fandom
five trivia show on friday
once again that will be on the topic of
zazu
and disney um so no pixar no star wars
no marvel just the core disney stuff
uh you sign on by using that link in the
description
you get there friday uh some point
during the day i'm sure it tells you
then
and you answer them questions and win
that real money then come back and
buy us something nice um
yeah now let's uh now let's watch some
uh deleted scenes if we have any
story gi jade
dexter elizabeth warren in the army show
li shang part 1 li shang part 2
the boys transformers mage of extinction
crazy witch asians con man
and don't leave me [ __ ] so gently though
you know it's a good thing donnie and
saw her heroic act to save the army
that's why i trust her to lead them
later
you will lead us as we ride to the
imperial city oh wait nobody saw that
well that's a weird choice uh quick say
something about chi
only the most true will connect deeply
to his chi
gotta love that chi so how about the chi
baby
it's like the last dragon and how they
use glow that's just this movie and
cheese yeah
also hearing the word chi together so
many times just reminded me of chi
chi's did you guys have chichi sure yeah
i know chichi from dbz different
yeah it was like yeah very americanized
mexican food chain
sometimes that hits the spot yeah got a
big big ol i imagine like the big plates
of the orange rice the beans and the
meat
you know a lot of cheese like tex-mex
exactly
yes yeah exactly yeah you're putting it
in my veins all right uh
let's see what the comments had to say
uh john bainbridge writes
is there any animated disney movie that
does need a live-action disney remake
anything left on there i've long thought
that uh
sword and the stone would work really
well because
uh like the the movie is so we like i
remember that movie
when i was a kid i'm sort of nostalgic
for it but it's such a weird
take on that story it's mostly like what
if you turned into a squirrel and then a
lady squirrel fell in love with you like
it has so little to do
with king arthur and merlin and then
sword tournament and everything like you
could do a really cool movie that was
like more focused
and less like a fancy animal stuff
you could honestly get a franchise out
of it because sword and the stone was
like an animated adaptation of like a
little chunk of the once in future king
exactly exactly and yes it's weird
because everyone keeps trying to figure
out how to crack king arthur
and it's it's you know like what if he
was a streetwise
urchin and uh and they did crimes
and they talked about the crimes and
cool like jump cuts or
whatever but it's like just do once a
future king no like exactly and like you
could do like you could get
three or four like disney five action
adventure medieval magic sorcery
movies out of that and like yeah you
know you could do again like like
you do nods to the stuff that's in the
cartoon but you don't have to use that
cartoon as the template just use the
book as the template
or the legends themselves all right um
i'm gonna say cars uh i wanna see
a cronenbergish uh body horror version
of the film cars
yeah i wanna see owen wilson play a car
uh i want yeah so it's like that one
scene in southland tales but for the
whole movie
yes exactly exactly
so sean smith writes uh what will be the
next 30
disney plus movie or maybe what should
be the next 30 disney plus movie
anything
upcoming that you would uh that you
would drop 30 for that would maybe make
sense for disney
i i mean i know things that i would drop
30 for i don't think they make sense for
disney i'll drop 30
for black widow but i don't think that's
a good business move for disney to like
burn that one i don't think they can
make their money
back on stuff like black widow doing it
this way you know
like it's just too expensive to pay for
up front
the uh the next likely one apparently is
soul would you guys spend 30 bucks on
seoul the new pixar movie
maybe i mean maybe is it coming out
three yeah
later it's my turn
the gardeners come yeah it's like is it
if it's gonna come out
three months later for free on disney
plus you know probably not
like that that's a that's a that's a
high hurdle for me to jump
you know i can see them watching the
finished product of this um
anthropomorphic uh remake of the fox
robin hood they're gonna do
i could see them looking at that final
product and being like let's just do the
disney plus 30
on this nightmare maybe i paid for
dollars to see that nightmare
as would i uh and finally rob turner
asks uh what
what about the other way around what
disney or slash
connected live action story should be
animated his example is pulp fiction
with talking guns and that's also
my answer wait that supreme roger rabbit
isn't it
so any movie can get an animated
disney version of it
yeah yeah well pulp fiction was that was
that touchdown
it's disney it's the miramax or miramax
which was disney owned
yeah i guess yeah yeah okay so
we'll keep it under the disney umbrellas
yeah
uh huh this is hard um
well who did uh let's see what studio
did um
i don't know i think you could do a fun
hocus pocus i don't think you need to
touch hocus pocus but
that that could be a fun cartoon that's
disney right
yeah you could do a you could do a hocus
pocus cartoon for sure that'd be awesome
yeah there you go um i'd do the aviator
oh i know uh now that disney owns fox
you do the alien franchise anime oh i
would
love an animated alien movie here's your
answer yeah why
like just give us yeah like really get
the and flux people back
yeah like like very cool stylized
uh that's how you sort of relaunch and
now you don't need that it doesn't need
to be tied to ripley it's just like more
alien adventures
yeah no no you you have about a young
ripley
and uh and she asked her like here's
what i want from the world song
in the first 10 minutes and then the
introducing the derelict ship song
the big makeover scene where they make
her a a jumpsuit
yeah just another jumpsuit sure all
right
yeah yeah they're talking a talking
headcrab uh sidekick yeah where they
first
found jonesy the cat you know we see how
it all started
yeah the cat's voiced by eddie murphy
sure oh good times
all right uh that's all for questions
thank you guys so much for joining me
and thank you guys so much for watching
i hope you come back next week when we
will be doing something
very streamy heavily heavily
streamy um so there's your clue
you're not gonna guess it because we've
never really done something like this
before so we're excited to do that and
talk to you about it next week
right here on oz trailer commentaries
we'll see you tomorrow for sju see you
on the phantom five
see you wherever you are bye-bye
[Music]
you